With the MCU turning 22 films old upon the
release of Avengers: Endgame, many fans are
using their considerable expertise to guide
newcomers through Marvel's complex timeline.
But taking into consideration story flow,
chronology, and plain common sense, just what
is the best way to enjoy the franchise?
With an emphasis on how all the movies link
together, and how to have the best viewing
experience possible, here's the order we think
is the best.
Captain America: The First Avenger may be
the earliest setting the MCU has explored,
but the franchise was born with 2008's Iron
Man, and it was Robert Downey Jr. and his
genius billionaire playboy philanthropist
who became the beating heart of Marvel’s
narrative.
Almost everything we associate with the MCU
begins here: the origin story of the flawed
but lovable hero, the graceful interweaving
of elements from the larger Marvel narrative,
and of course the compulsory post-credits
scene, teasing larger things to come.
Even if it's not first in the timeline, the
birth of the narrative was Iron Man, and no
Marvel movie marathon should begin with anything
else.
Iron Man 2 hit theaters two years after The
Incredible Hulk, but there are a couple of
reasons why you should watch Tony and Rhodey
take out Whiplash's drones before Ed Norton's
lone MCU feature.
First, although chronology isn’t the most
important thing to take into consideration
here, the events of Iron Man 2 mostly take
place before Incredible Hulk.
Then again, judging by the news footage of
the Hulk's rampages that can seen in the background
of the film's penultimate scene, there is
at least some overlap between the two movies'
timelines.
Second, and most importantly, with Tony agreeing
to become a S.H.I.E.L.D.
consultant at the end of Iron Man 2, watching
this movie first helps make sense of his appearance
at the end of the next one.
Instead of a mid or post-credits scene, The
Incredible Hulk features a short final scene
which tied the events of the movie to the
larger Marvel narrative.
"What if I told you we were putting a team
together?"
"Who's 'we'?"
Considering the tenor of Ross and Stark's
conversation, it seems likely that the original
plan was to follow the trajectory of the comics
and have the origin of the Avengers begin
with a hunt for the Hulk.
After plans changed, however, this scene stuck
out like a sore thumb.
Marvel's solution was to release the short
film The Consultant on the Thor Blu-ray, which
we'll include as a necessary watch after Incredible
Hulk, but before Thor.
It features two conversations between S.H.I.E.L.D.
agents Phil Coulson and Jasper Sitwell.
One of the chats takes place before Incredible
Hulk's final scene…
"If we want the general to refuse this request,
then we have to send someone who will truly
annoy him."
And the other conversation takes place after
Incredible Hulk's final scene.
"Apparently the Consultant outdid himself;
Ross got so mad he tried to have him removed
from the bar."
"How'd that go over?"
"Stark bought the place."
As a result, Tony Stark's fruitless conversation
with the General never goes anywhere exactly
as "planned" and fits nicely into MCU continuity
after all.
Agent Coulson exits the story in Iron Man
2 when a S.H.I.E.L.D.
assignment calls him to New Mexico.
We catch up with him after that film's credits
as he locates Thor's hammer in the desert,
marking the first time a Marvel post-credit
scene directly overlapped with an upcoming
film.
It's also one of the reasons shifting Iron
Man 2's placement helps during a marathon
otherwise, Thor follows Iron Man 2 immediately.
This way, however, you get the tease of the
hammer at the end of Iron Man 2 and are made
to wait through Incredible Hulk for the tantalizing
payoff.
It’s also worth considering that Thor and
Captain America should be watched back-to-back.
Not only because they contrast wonderfully
in their settings and each kick off in Norway,
but also because the two movies work together
to launch the cosmic side of the MCU with
a basic concept: that science and magic could
be seen as "one and the same."
A lot of Marvel fans will tell you that Captain
America: The First Avenger should be watched
first, since most of its story takes place
first chronologically.
But the movie is fine right where it is, coming
after Thor, and don't let anyone tell you
differently.
To really understand this movie’s place
in the franchise, it’s important to take
into account what happens to Cap at the end
of the film.
"You've been asleep, Cap.
For almost seventy years."
Without the Iron Man, Hulk, and Thor films,
this ending just doesn't work!
That's why The First Avenger shouldn't be
the first movie in your marathon.
But after Thor and before Avengers?
It's perfect.
Speaking of which...
There’s something uniquely satisfying about
watching all five of the first MCU movies
and then seeing so many of those characters
unite in The Avengers.
That satisfaction would work against a largely
chronological viewing of the films in a couple
of ways.
The Avengers belongs right after Captain America
firstly because of the importance the Tesseract
plays in both, and because of how Cap's "man
out of time" theme informs his arc in The
Avengers.
But a chronological viewing order would also
place 2019’s Captain Marvel in the number
two spot, and unless you haven’t noticed
Carol Danvers is nowhere to be seen in The
Avengers.
Watching her origin story then experiencing
every Phase One hero except her come together
in The Avengers would be needlessly jarring.
Although The Winter Soldier was actually the
third movie release in Phase Two, there's
at least one good reason to watch it first.
One of the more valid criticisms of Marvel
Studios' second phase is that the Avengers
never really helped each other out, even as
each of the heroes found themselves in need
of help.
The Winter Soldier offers an explanation for
this issue, since the movie ends with the
disbandment of S.H.I.E.L.D., which brought
the Avengers together in the first place.
Without Nick Fury there to bring them together,
coordination between the Avengers may have
been more difficult, hence Thor and Stark
going solo in their next appearances.
The Dark World is probably best right after
The Winter Soldier.
You can't push it too far down the order,
because it's the first time we see Loki answering
for his crimes against Earth, but it also
can't come immediately after The Avengers.
After all, The Dark World shows us the aftermath
of Jane Foster’s discovery that Thor came
to Earth to fight the Chitauri but didn't
bother to drop her a line before or after.
Coming so hot on the heels of The Avengers,
her frustration might seem a little strange.
One of the most important aspects of Iron
Man 3 is Tony's space-induced PTSD, since
it explains just why Stark is willing to risk
so much in Age of Ultron.
Giving two movies of space in between Avengers
and Iron Man 3 is helpful for this, since
it demonstrates that he's had some time for
his trauma to simmer.
Placing it later in the viewing order than
The Winter Soldier would also explain why
the destruction of Tony’s home and kidnapping
of the President don’t rate highly on the
S.H.I.E.L.D.
priority list, again, because they’re not
around anymore.
There isn't much to tie Guardians of the Galaxy
to the rest of the MCU, so you might think
you could watch it at any point in your marathon.
The only tangible connection was the brief
appearance of Thanos, who'd been introduced
during the credits of The Avengers.
But the Mad Titan is also the exact reason
why you should make sure to put Guardians
right after Iron Man 3 and before Age of Ultron
in your viewing order.
"Fine, I'll do it myself."
This mid-credits scene from the Avengers'
first sequel marks the end of Thanos' strategy
of acquiring the Infinity Stones through intermediaries.
If Guardians doesn't stay before Age of Ultron,
Thanos' mid-credits proclamation doesn't make
sense.
Avengers: Age of Ultron's spot is a pretty
solid no-brainer.
The dissolution of both S.H.I.E.L.D. and Hydra,
as well as Maria Hill's career move to Stark
Industries, both happen in Winter Soldier.
We see the results of Stark's trauma in Iron
Man 3, which push him to create Ultron in
secret.
Finally, Thor's knowledge of the Infinity
Stones in Ultron comes, in part, from his
experiences during The Dark World.
The table is set for Age of Ultron's story,
so this one's placement is easy.
As the final film of Phase Two, Ant-Man is
firmly set between Avengers: Age of Ultron
and Captain America: Civil War.
We know it takes place after Age of Ultron,
partly because Scott tussles with Falcon in
full Avenger mode, and partly due to Hank
Pym's comments about the Battle of Sokovia.
"Besides, they’re probably too busy dropping
cities out of the sky."
We also know it takes place right before Civil
War because Ant-Man ends with Scott learning
that Falcon is looking for him and in Civil
War we find out exactly why.
There isn't anything too complicated to figure
out about the placement of Captain America:
Civil War.
Just sit back and enjoy the straight continuity
of Scott Lang’s arc from Ant-Man, and the
return of Cap’s new Avengers team, last
seen at the end of Age of Ultron.
What gets tricky, however, is what comes next
since Civil War introduces two new major heroes
to the MCU, who each need establishing along
with all the other characters Phase Three
brings to the franchise.
Although it wasn’t released until around
halfway through Phase Three, Black Panther
really does belong right after Civil War since
the events of Tony and Steve’s feud lead
directly to the crisis in Wakanda.
While we've broken with strictly chronological
viewings of the franchise earlier on in this
list, we want to strongly emphasize it here.
Few true Marvel Zombies would disagree that
waiting four films between Civil War and Black
Panther feels like far too long to wait to
see the next chapter in T'Challa's story.
Like Black Panther, the events of Spider-Man:
Homecoming follow directly from those of Captain
America: Civil War and even revisits some
of Civil War during its prologue.
"Okay, so the craziest thing just happened,
right?
I got in a fight with Captain America and
I stole his shield and I threw it at him and
I… uh, he's big now, I gotta go, hang on."
But it’s good to keep at least one movie
between Homecoming and Civil War, because
the end of Homecoming sees the return of Pepper
Potts to the franchise.
During Civil War, we learned that Pepper and
Tony were "taking a break," while in Homecoming
they seem perfectly happy with one another.
And everyone knows that fractured relationships
heal in exactly the amount of time it takes
for a Wakandan succession crisis to be resolved.
That's just common knowledge.
After Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 was released,
there was a lot of noise made by fans about
about Stan Lee's cameo mentioning his Civil
War appearance, despite James Gunn’s insistence
that the movie took place before the events
of Civil War.
Best thing to do here?
Don’t worry about it.
It takes place in space.
None of the Avengers are in it.
Forget about the nitty-gritty and just watch
Baby Groot dance.
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 is best served
here not for any chronological reason, but
because there are only two movies left before
Infinity War, and one of those is Thor: Ragnarok.
Guardians Vol. 2 and Ragnarok are both great
fun, but you don’t really need to put two
witty, snarky, intergalactic epics back-to-back.
There's an argument to be made to put this
movie closer to The Winter Soldier, since
Jasper Sitwell mentions Strange’s name in
a list of potential Hydra targets for Project:
Insight during the Captain America sequel:
"You, a TV anchor in Cairo, the undersecretary
of defense, a high school valedictorian in
Iowa City, Bruce Banner, Stephen Strange,
anyone who's a threat!"
But that tease is pretty vague, and Hydra's
pretty evil.
Who knows why they're targeting a rich surgeon
in Manhattan?
So even though Sitwell's threat could place
this film earlier on our list, it's still
better off right here.
Doctor Strange's placement also breaks up
two space-based flicks: Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2 and Thor: Ragnarok.
And considering Doctor Strange's mid-credits
scene is in fact a little slice of Ragnarok,
it's nice to get those two movies back-to-back.
When fans experienced Ragnarok's mid-credits
scene in theaters, it was difficult to imagine
that the looming shadow was from anything
but Thanos' ship.
At the time, that was an almost cruelly tantalizing
tease for the next step in Thor’s journey.
Now that Avengers: Infinity War has been released
and the brutal fate awaiting Loki, Heimdall,
and the other doomed passengers has become
clear, it feels a little strange not to watch
Ragnarok right before Infinity War, especially
considering the first thing audiences hear
in Infinity War is the Asgardian refugee ship's
distress call.
Sticking with Marvel Studios' order of release
which puts Black Panther after Ragnarok just
doesn’t make a whole lot of sense.
Marvel Studios put some unbelievable time,
effort, and money into the build-up to Avengers:
Infinity War, and you have to believe they
had a reason to release it when they did.
Yes, they may have put fans through torture
by putting two movies between Infinity War
and its resolution but, by this point, Marvel
is at the top of its game.
The studio's not going to steer you wrong,
here.
Trust in Feige, and try to remember that there’s
probably no good reason to move Infinity War
any closer to its conclusion in Avengers:
Endgame.
For the most part, Ant-Man and the Wasp seems
to take place at roughly the same time as
Infinity War.
And in the mid-credits scene we see the latter
movie’s devastating effects take hold on
Scott Lang’s world.
"Hank, quit screwing around, you told me yourself
not to screw around.
Hank!
Hope?"
But don’t be tempted to move Ant-Man and
the Wasp to an earlier place in your viewing
order.
Not only does this movie give away what happens
during Infinity War, but it also provides
some much-needed laughter after the massive
downer that was Infinity War’s ending.
Why take the chaser before the shot?
Because Captain Marvel makes such a point
of its ‘90s setting, those arguing for a
strictly chronological viewing would happily
move this movie all the way to the beginning
of Phase One.
But doing that will seriously affect your
enjoyment of Avengers: Endgame.
The first meeting between Carol Danvers and
the Avengers is sure to be a huge moment for
the franchise.
If Marvel had told these stories chronologically,
however, and released Captain Marvel twenty
films ago without mentioning her again since,
would that still be the case?
Think of it this way: there’s a reason why
Pulp Fiction earned its place in cinema history.
Sometimes, for a story to make any kind of
sense, you have to tell it out of order.
And the fact that this franchise is as good
as it is… well, Nick Fury himself thinks
it could even be divine intervention:
"What happened here was a miracle!
And I want you to f------ acknowledge it!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.